foreign
[Music]
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
the meeting of the audit and governments
committee on Tuesday the 18th of July
before we start the agenda formally I'm
just going to go around the table so
that we can all introduce ourselves my
name is Philip Hackett and I'm the
chairman
to my left is Peter Hudson I'm the
deputies
Steve Hurst should be back there
Paul middle Mass from Devon old
departure
services
thank you very much
item one on the agenda
apologies for absence to receive
apologies for absence for the meeting
um do we have an account yes chair we've
had apologies from councilor gub
thank you very much
item two confirmation of the minutes
on pages three to ten
the first set of minutes relate to the
meeting on the 4th of April so as I'm
the only person present in that meeting
here today
we'll formally note those if we may
and on Tuesday the 27th of June
um rather than do a quick page Turner is
there anything on those minutes that you
wish to bring to my attention
otherwise I'm happy to propose from the
chair that they are a true record of
events
thank you David
all those in favor
cute that's unanimous
Declaration of Interest that's item
three members with interest should refer
to the agenda item and describe the
nature of their interest when the item
is considered
right okay
we've been around the table to introduce
ourselves would you like to introduce
yourself to the meeting
thank you very much cancer Ford
going back item Four Agreements of
agenda items part one and two
um
we do not have a closed item this
afternoon
so we need not take a vote on that and
that's correct chair
yep and move straight on to item five
which is urgent matters brought forward
with Mission the chair
I have no items and no no items forward
so on to item six the draft statement of
accounts
2022-23 and to receive a verbal update
and financial statements 2022-23 from
the section 151 officer Peter
thank you chair good afternoon
councilors good afternoon everyone
so the draft financial statements have
been published on the website for the 20
22-23 Financial year and we'll just do a
short presentation
um
going through these and to give a
members an overview of what what they
entail so what are the financial
statements these are backward looking
financial position of the council at the
31st of March 2023
they are
quite complex and require translation
formulated on a different basis than our
management accounts which are reported
in our quarterly budget report to
internal overview and scrutiny
they're subject to external audit and
they provide reassurance that figures
present it present a fair representation
of the council's financial position
external audit work provides a degree of
assurance regarding
efficiency and control and robustness of
the financial team
the devil's in the detail so to speak
so there are four key statements in the
statement of accounts statement accounts
is quite a quite a large document but
this is the key for notes really which
show the council's position so first we
have the comprehensive income and
expenditure
and note one which is the funding
analysis which we'll go through in a
minute Note 2 is um or the second one
rather is the movement in reserve
statements
then we have the balance sheet and
finally the cash flow
so first of these is comprehensive
income and expenditure accounts this is
sort of the the
peer now as you would have as a normal
business so to speak
um
so here here the overall figure is that
we've got 12 836
000 which represents the cost of
providing the council services
includes income and expenditure and some
grants created directly to Services
also some depreciation impairments of
assets which are not
and these are amounts which aren't
included in the quarterly management
accounts
um then slightly don't lower down on
this note we've got other operating
expenditure which is largely the precept
we give to the we pay to the Paris and
we'll collect and pay to the parishes
also other items being sort of pension
admin and lost gains and losses and
disposal of assets
we've then got financing investment
income which includes cash payments
relating to servicing of loans
physical cash due to short-term treasury
deposits which we've got over half a
million last year
and then any gains from investment
properties and as well sort of
non-cashment items which sort of
interest on the defined pension
liability and then finally on this part
we've got tax and non-specific grants
and this includes sort of council tax
income business rates income and other
central government grants which aren't
credited to the services
um then slightly further down on the
Note below this line we've got the
Surplus or deficit on the evaluation of
property and plant and equipment
so this reflects an upward evaluation of
the council's properties this isn't real
cash
um it reflects we have the district
valuer who values our properties each
year so it values their valuation of the
council's assets
and then below that we have a
re-measurement of the defined benefit
pension liability so this is the pension
scheme accounts was liable for which is
revalued each year in line with the way
the markets move and the values within
it again this isn't real income Council
hasn't received 38 million but it's a
favorable movement in sort of future
future liabilities and assumptions on
corporate bond yields Etc
so the next the next note is so sort of
an analysis note and this um this note
provides the link between our quarterly
reporting and
the Surplus on the provision of services
on the CIS that we just looked at
so this goes from left to right so we've
got as reported in the qbr is that is
the first column and that that Nets down
to nil because we um
we run a balanced I've always tried to
get a balanced budget and this is after
the out term Surplus has been
transferred to Reserves we then the next
column is the expenditure chargeable to
the general fund not included in
reporting this includes reallocation of
funding tax and non-specific Grant
income depreciation and impairment on
assets and Paris presets
and the net movement on the general fund
Reserves
so then we have adjustment between
funding and accounting basis so this is
so the taxpayers not charged for items
in Note 2 so example depreciation
charges are reversed so these are not
born by the taxpayer and this this links
the two really this this note
so the next the next um major note is
the movement in reserve statement so
this is really just a picture of the
reserves that the council hold and this
is split between usable Reserve which
really represent the cash that the
council has and non-usable Reserve which
are more accounting convention
reserves so they're often related to
revaluation of property so that
say that sort of local government
statute so it's really the it's probably
the usable reserves which are more
more relevant to members from that
perspective and um so in this you can
see
but overall we've got total usable
reserves of 16 million
representing the cash that the physical
cash and Investments that the council
holds
so finally we well next we're moving on
to the balance sheet so in simple terms
this is the assets that the
Council has and the liabilities so the
assets would be land and buildings
investment properties vehicles and cash
and debtors which is money owned to the
council and the liabilities would be
creditors which is money we owed we owe
to people other liabilities such as
pension deficits and any outstanding
loans
and then the net net of these two
um really back up the councils usable
and unusable Reserves
so on the balance sheet we've got
um
so here we've got the London buildings
really which are valued by the district
valuer
um and including sort of plant equipment
and the council's Frontline vehicle free
Fleet that's that's the Top Line
uh
so that's that's the 40 40 million we
have out of there then we have some
Heritage assets which is some statues we
have in parks and um The Collection at
the bottom
and we then have intangible assets which
is largely written down but include some
some remaining sort of software licenses
we have investment properties which we
only have a few but it's the land at the
um the Burrows with the We Rent Out to
the north Royal North Devon golf course
and the beach Huts as well a large
amount of that we also have some
long-term debtors
made up of balance of a loan made to
Atlantic racket Center deposits for
homelessness
we then have a shorter term investments
which is largely treasury deposit so
this is generally treasury deposit so
it's money we put out to earn interest
for the council as part of our treasury
policy which we only place to
institutions with our form rating
we then have shorter term debtors which
is money to own to the council from sort
of our trade debtors and taxpayers and
some government grants
and lastly a sort of cash cash
equivalence which is the balance on the
council's bank account at the balance
sheet day
then we're moving on to the liability
side so we've got creditors short-term
creditors be the largest item which is
sort of Grants received in advance money
owns Which is money therefore money owed
to central government
and such as housing benefit subsidy
business rate income
we have some Provisions which is largely
well wholly explained by the business
rate appeals and provision and we have
some short-term borrowing
um so we have some borrowing from the
public works loan board
um due and so this is the amount which
is due within within 12 months
there is also some long-term borrowing
which is amount due longer than 12
months also the pwlb
then finally we have the pension
liability so it's an assessment of the
underlying deficit on the pension fund
so there's a quite complex calculations
valued by actuaries each year
expects in practice to achieve greater
return on investments and payments
payments of this underlying deficit are
included in the ceis
so here we've got the again so this is
the reserves part of the balance sheet
has seen sort of on the nurse statement
earlier so we've got the unusable
reserves um at the top there section 31
million and then we've got the usable
reserves of the 16 million so they're
they're the they're effectively
represent our cash that we hold so
they're largely earmarked or Capital
Reserves
out of capital purposes
and so finally we have the cash flow
statement so
the sort of last major statement
showing how the cache has moved
throughout the year and where each
where's the cash where is it's moved
through so we start off with a surplus
on the provision of surfaces it shows I
mean and shows up at the end
and shows up with movement and cash
balance at the end of the year so
um
so that's the first line then we can we
add 1.3 million for sort of non-cash eye
items depreciation movement in pension
Etc and we sort of deduct 2.3 million of
capital items which is proceeds from
sale of assets and capital grants
um then a bit lower down we've
got cash which relates to investing
activities so this is purchase of some
assets
and return of short-term treasury
deposits
financing
the financing activities is repayments
of short-term loans which we didn't have
any in 2223
and then finally so that gives us the
movement of cash which is the reduction
of four million during the year
um so then finally the the main
difference or one of the main changes in
the accounts
um in 2223 was the incorporation of
active torrage our Leisure subsidiary so
this is the first year
um where we've had active torrich as
it's a subsidiary we have to consolid we
consolidate it into the accounts
so
so the Consolidated accounts where we
basically add them up and then remove
the transactions between the two so we
don't double counting which is largely
the management fee so we can see on the
left there we've got storage accounts
values and then the Consolidated so the
cost of service only moves slightly
which is just six grand which is the
active storage Surplus for the year
and then the other major categories are
the cash we're incorporating active
torridges bank balance effectively of
just uh just over two hundred thousand
and then also including some active
storage creditors and
removing some debtors which is money
that the um
active torrage owed to the council for
utilities which we pay or never have
and
that's a
well a very quick short brief brief
overview of our accounts and really it's
just over to members and I've got any
questions
um
thank you very much Peter for a very
concise
run through of the accounts
um members do you have any questions
can't afford yeah
[Music]
normally people like to mute me but I do
like a sense of umatron thank you for
that
so don't take anything personal we've
got to get to know one another and
obviously any cancer at the moment up
and down the country is facing you know
difficult times
so what I would like you to do sometime
via Tom if you could give me your remit
because you obviously a one five officer
which involves both accountancy whether
what if you're sit for whatever I'll
just like to know what you've actually
got right it's not a this is a you know
representing taxpayers or whatever so
I'd like to know that no you're right
has three quarters give it a
presentation what I'd also like to ask
through the chair right it's not being
personal to anybody
but it's important out of the councilors
around the table I'd like to know if
anybody's got any accountancy
qualifications at all because when we're
scrutinizing it does concern me on many
many layers that's what I'm simply
saying is I'm not being personal
um but you know you need to be
scrutinized so do I counselor Ford I
think we're strained from the agenda
item
well actually we're on about see this is
where you're very good at being a flying
monkey I'm asking something forward well
I want Bob for asking any questions
that's fine
that's right move on ask questions
relevant to the agenda right it is when
you're scrutinizing figures if you don't
know anything about how to scrutinize
them how can you screen eyes up that's a
simple question
we're receiving
pretty good
okay thank you
any further question counselors
I'm only asking
um
well if you don't know the subject
you're happy that's fine
differ we agree to differ
we agree to differ
it was a very good report Peter thank
you very much and like we said we're
here to hear your report and we have
Auditors to raise issues
that might give them concerns
right so if there are no further
questions I'll simply note the report
and move back to you again Peter for the
going concern report on pages 11 to 18.
Peter
thank you um
no presentations for this one so this is
the report in the pack
so this is a just so this is a report
basically
going through the concept of the going
concern it's all stipulating the report
but basically concept going to concern
which is an important one which our
external Auditors always look at in
detail which is just which is assuming
that um
an institution or the the council is
ongoing and has long term
long-term viability and so this report
sets out
um
set sound
that basis so to speak so it sets is
this on a few different factors so the
council's current financial position
um the way we're projecting the
financial position going forward over
the next few years it has a look at the
council's balance sheet and the cash
flow and the governance Arrangements of
the council and the regulatory
environment which we're in and I'm not
planning to go through the report in in
detail and all the information
is there but happy to take any questions
that anyone anyone would have
on it
right that that's fine thank you Peter
it's um a straightforward
any any yes yeah okay I have written
down I say with the questions I'll try
to
um refer to where they are in the report
but I'm a bit clumsy then apologies for
that
[Music]
um
can I have any clarification on on the
contributions to reserves can you just
outline some of the things that maybe
aren't obvious as to me as to what they
actually are so the general contribution
to Capital in a nutshell what's that
I'm on page uh 12 of the report pack I
don't know of the agenda pattern
says general General contribution to
Capital
0.18 million
so I
I think that's I believe that's a
let me just check them I believe that's
the contribution to the current parking
so there's a ongoing car parking Capital
program that we have
um and a general property one which
where we put money away each each year
um so really to put money away so we can
resurface the car parks
and the um The Apprentice Reserve is
that where we are we've taken money out
because we've
got a graduate at the council this year
is that what's going on yeah I think
yeah yeah we've got a couple of
apprentices so that's where we've taken
out money
um to fund those okay and transfer to
Property Maintenance backlog yeah sorry
so so yeah the top one's the car parking
so the
sorry this is the um yeah we have a
property backlog maintenance Reserve
sort of a planned maintenance that the
property team
um sort of register each year so we try
to keep that top top so to speak
and then lots of references made to the
tgfr transition government funding
Reserve what what is that what what is
it for does it do
um really that's the that's Steve
probably knows the history a bit more
detail than I do but
um obviously over a period of time
government grants and things have been
reduced in uh councils budgets Under
Pressure so we've sent money aside to
manage the long-term or medium-term
financial position of of the council so
that when you come to budget setting you
don't have big shocks and that money can
then be used and set aside for
transformation type things so if you
know you've got a budget deficit and you
know you're going to do a piece of work
to reduce that Deb said it gives the the
council and counselors the time and
opportunity to feed those into the
budget process
just like a privilege Society account to
be like it's there to use and to manage
Peaks shop Peaks trusts and shocks in
the finances of the council okay so the
money
to it is coming from our own budget that
we've set aside previously yes okay
okay thank you and then there's mention
I don't even know if I can find the page
on it on to do with pensions and it says
that the pen the council's pension
scheme liabilities has reduced quite a
lot compared to what you were expecting
I don't know what page that was on now
sorry I should have written down a paper
yeah page 15 into page 16.
um it said that the employee no I don't
know if that's right it said that
um
the liability the the council's pension
scheme liability has reduced
significantly and I just wondered what's
brought that about is it kind of General
Finance that's happening
in the world or I don't know I don't
know much about pensions but what is it
that's made it different from what
you're expecting
yeah
it comes from the Actuarial valuation so
they value the pension scheme every year
so it's it's pretty pretty complicated
even even from yeah even for us to
understand
um
so to speak so I think it's largely them
um valuing the Investments based on the
world so it is more the way corporate
more the way the bonds have moved we've
had large interest rate movements
um
then probably you know and then there's
sort of General trends of demographics
Etc within that as well but it's those
movements especially large movements are
probably more based on short-term
financing
um
sort of build into it but that's yeah
that's why it moves quite quite
significantly but it's obviously quite a
big big schemes if that makes sense okay
but it's nothing that we need to worry
about it's not sort of
real money in in a sense is kind of
ongoing
evaluations the real money in the fact
that but their sort of estimations of
the future in some respect that doesn't
mean you don't have
doesn't mean you don't have a um
a real liability there
um and that every you know we have a we
have a
pension liability so to speak which we
are which we
into and to reduce the deficit every
year so there's a real liability which
we pay but there can be quite large
swings year to year on these things
do I keep asking questions or do you
want me to stop certainly so balance
sheets 31st of March
mentions the list of assets councils net
assets amounted to
47.428 million pounds I know that there
has been an issue ongoing that was
raised by one of my ward members about
finding the Torres District Council
asset list
um online and there's maybe I I don't I
just wondered
um
if when I'm assuming that we know what
our assets are and that someone kind of
knows even though it's not published to
the public we have a list of fixed
assets that we then value or is this I
don't know what I'm saying I'm just
saying if there's no if we haven't put
out the pub the list of we haven't
actually got a list of assets I can't
see a list of assets of what the council
actually owns I don't really know what
this money kind of represents Steve
um probably you should say I'm sorry I
know some of the backgrounds what you're
talking about cancer right so there is
there is a an athletes list uh that's
been updated by our property manager
John Wynn and his team it was on our
previous
website but it's in the transition to a
new website for whatever reason it
didn't transfer across so it's been
updated uh John's come back from leave
today yesterday and is just validating
that before it goes live on the system
so behind that there's obviously a list
of assets which the finance team have
and hold for different purposes because
they're more interested in the the
accounting value so there's different
values for different types of assets
there's account and accounting value and
market value there there's a range of
different things so in here we're
looking at the accounting value of
assets so that would be everything that
the council launch that we need to
account fall into different forms and
bases
can't afford just two things actually
um first we sponsor cancer bright was I
believe and this is where I'm concerned
because I believe
I'm I believe the World is Flat there's
not any global warming you know a woman
I don't deal with that but go and pick
up this point which is really important
I can't actually values I understand
microphone so actually who comes up with
the accountancy value is that internal
external how do we get that because that
will change almost daily so it needs to
be upgraded obviously every 12 months
but who actually says what something is
worth
uh so Peter referred to that in his
presentation the district valuer values
the asset
yes
yes I've gone green
um
the list of investment properties is
that included in the asset list
uh yes it will be so it's it is yeah so
I think in the list they referred to
beach huts and some other yeah yeah okay
but that's included in the asset list
okay
um reserves
um 16.1 million in cash
um what was it in the previous years
I've got a plus or minus figure a
variance
probably similar okay I'd say it's
around the 15 16 million Mark okay how
consistent is that
um
I would say since I've been here I'd say
it's probably
probably reasonably consistent it
changed a bit during covid just due to
various scrap monies we were holding and
covert depending on the timings of what
the grants were given out
but that cash balance has generally
stayed around that okay just is that
Reserves
volume not value amount dictated in some
sort of legislation I.E there's x amount
of
money coming in from rates for instance
and therefore a percentage of that has
to be in reserves how is it who decides
on how much should stay in reserves
um
well I I don't believe there's any
stipulation of what you have to hold so
to speak I think it's more down to
members and obviously
if the counts with running surpluses or
deficits um
so that's why we have reserves such as
the transition and government funding
financing which way we've decided to put
money aside for for those sort of the
variation but I don't think that's I'm
not aware of that being required by
legislation
just just to address the whilst that
sounds like the majority of that is your
mind for specific capital projects so if
we looked at that figure in conjunction
with the council's capital program and
the funding of capital program that's
where most of that is sat so if you
think we uh in the process of building
or building an environment Center we
have to replace our vehicles for example
most of ourselves for that purpose the
bit that you were talking about Heralds
just again adjusting case and for the
m4c events I think it's about 1.2
million which is generally regarded
around 10 to 15 of the council's net
revenue spend is a good uh Benchmark
figure and periodically then that figure
is
risk assessed against things the
councils and operations the council has
so the typical type of expenditure and
the typical exposure to risk against
those elements of expenditure just to
kind of make sure that a reasonable
signing to hold in place of unforeseen
events okay so the reserves figure it
at 16 million 16.1 million is actually
can be subdivided so the actual
emergency fund level if I call it that
is 1.2 million you say right okay
it seemed an awful at 16 seemed an awful
lot of money just to be floating around
and such but it's not that it's 1.2 yeah
we've got a capital program of 25
million so a large part of that is
okay thank you
yeah cash flow questions the council's
cash flow
um I'd maybe just would like you just to
verb verbally help me get these numbers
right if that's okay so
um 15.3 million pounds of short-term
Investments
and then we're borrowing not with of
borrowing we've got 0.357 million and
then in the council's current account
they're 6.4 million
and so cash balances are
the current bank account and short-term
treasury deposits less the borrowing
which is predicted to be around 15
million pounds as of March 31st
but if you
add the short-term Investments to the
current account 15.3 million plus 6.4
million
gives you 22
million so we're just assuming that
we're going to have
less than that
so I'm looking at page 16 it says it
says the council is predicting to have
cash balances of around 15 million
pounds as or 31st of March 2024 fine it
says that that figure is the current
bank account 6.4 million and short-term
treasury deposits well if you add those
two numbers together that's all I'm
asking if you add those two raw numbers
together 15.3 million plus 6.4 million
you don't get 15 million that's all I
was checking yes sorry I'm I'm with you
now yeah this is sort of this is looking
towards the end of the year so we've got
some got a few reasonably large capital
projects um
like the environment Center going on so
we're sort of estimating so really
you've got your reserves your 16 million
but actually if you go out and build a
five million pound building then
obviously though that drops down so your
cash balance drops down so yes that
basically at the start of the year we
would have had
on deposit um like you said the 15
million
and the 6.4 is effectively your cash
your Investments plus your cash so to
speak but then we're just we're looking
forward to say in in the context of
going concerned that the council's on an
ongoing business to say that actually
yeah we'll we're forecasting we're going
to spend some of that but we're still
going to have 15 million at the end of
the year so these the big spends are the
environment Center mainly mainly I mean
any Capital project will obviously will
run run the capital reserves down so to
speak so it's kind of predicting what
we're spending and when and the timing
is obviously difficult of that we're
just estimating that
so as many councils will know that the
environment Center has been delayed a
little bit so to speak
thank you that's helpful
all right
no further questions
right then we would note your report
thank you Peter and move on to item
eight
which is approved of the whistleblowing
and anti-fraud policies and that's paid
and uh
so we're receiving a report again from
you Peter
thank you chair
um
so every three years auditing governance
is one of the tasks is to review and
update and any updates to the anti-fraud
corruption bribery policy and the
whistlebwelling blowing policy so
um
so these have been sort of reviewed by
the section 151 officer David Hayes went
through these and updated them
accordingly so it's really just for you
to review
um
any comments
right well
thank you very much Peter
um
as I said this is a review of the
ongoing policies that we've had
does anybody have any comments that they
wish to make on the actual policies
that are before us
no right well we would
yeah
I have one small suggestion actually I
thought that it was like very clear what
was going on in both policies and
obviously they get regular review which
is great and it says that the um
whistleblowing policy is communicated
clearly to staff members which I'm sure
that it is but um I come from a teaching
background and if for safeguarding for
example we all have lanyards like we
wear to go to the council and on the
back of them we have a really kind of
simple easy clarifying if you need to
talk to somebody about something these
people you should go to when I felt like
if you were going to
um
have a cause for whistleblowing it might
be a barrier to you to you doing it if
you felt like it was difficult for you
to access the information in any way or
sometimes you want to act quite quickly
before things get cold maybe you want to
do something immediately and I'm
wondering if maybe that's something we
could think about we've got a big blank
space on the back of our Council Badges
and I imagine staff maybe do too and I
wondered if there's room for us making
it really clear if you're if you've got
a concern contact this this and this so
that there's no lengthy process go on to
the staff intranet or whatever it is go
through the policy then find out who's
your contact it's just a suggestion
Jewish to make comments or just no I can
pick up chapter three with Council
approach and yeah
I
right so I'm happy to approve um
I'm happy to
um
say that we will approve these from the
chair I'm looking for a seconder
Cassie Branson
recommendation on page 18.
okay
previous episode
there's no there's no cover in my
thoughts to these policies but they do
need a program yeah so I'm happy to
recommend they are approved as stand
um so you're happy to approve a second
that David so all those in favor
those against
thank you for taking a vote
and
there are no abstentions that are
formerly asking potentials none
right
cute
we will now move on to
item number nine which are the agreed
audit actions report page 38
and again over to you Peter
ah thank you chair so this is just this
is
for the council to review and look at
the outstanding audit actions and we've
got four actions there
um from various different departments
um I won't read them out you can see
them in the report
it canceled if any questions on these
there's an update from the department
managers in the in the final column
um thank you very much okay
yes Paul
uh so so just to clarify these are
internal audit recommendations we've
made in our reports obviously management
have a process to
um consider which imagine actions have
been implemented so that's
um and they've they've identified these
four management actions are are in
essence late and I suppose they're
coming to you to say is this okay you
know what's the impact what's the risk
you you'll note that that two of them
are are medium priority and in terms of
so they're not high ones that need to be
done like yesterday so the median ones
and two two are low
um and um obviously it gives sort of um
some some sort of indication of of when
they're expected to be be implemented so
I just thought I'd clarify those points
to you
thank you
um
committee have any further comments on
that otherwise we will duly note
that's a gender item
and
move on to item number 10.
then load it
annual report page 39 to 55 and over to
you again Paul thank you yes thank you
so Pullman Mass from Devon audit
partnership and and first can I refer
you to Tony Rose to say hello
um
thank you Paul thank you Chad um so as
leaded to in the introduction from my
name's Tony Rosen the head of Devon
audit partnership
um one of the things I'm aiming to do um
given the breadth and scope of the
partnership is to come to the audit
committee where the end of year audit
opinion is given
um that's not to steal Paul's thunder in
delivering the hard work but it's to say
thank you very much in the first
instance to Paul and to the broader team
for doing that and if I'm honest as well
also to the officers in supporting it
because internal lord it's an
interesting function and and actually we
need the support boxers to be able to do
what we do so from my perspective thanks
welcome to new members as well and if
there's any questions moving forward
that you feel that Paul and myself can
help with we certainly will do and I'm
sure I will see a self-counselor Hackett
and at the devona partnership committee
and thank you for your efforts the other
day I'll get that on record as well for
trying to join that one thank you
yeah so uh just to introduce the report
then so this is our annual report for in
essence 22-23 so it's a financial year
ending the 31st of March 23.
um it provides an overview of of our
work that we did in year and we'll
inform your own annual gun statement
I'll just um highlight some of the
important areas of of Interest so
um page 41
this has our opinion statement in
essence providing a reasonable Assurance
opinion
there are there are three other opinion
opinions possible
um but a reasonable opinion sits in the
area where where most councils pretty
much all councils get a reasonable
Assurance opinion
but the table on the right on that page
provides our summary on the internal
control framework and also talks about
risk management and governments and
Performance Management
as you can see overall we we consider
that those those proportionate risk
management guns and and Performance
Management arrangements are in place for
the council
page 42
um has a Tabor table providing um or
listing all the
audits that we did in in a year and
where they sit in terms of the Assurance
opinion so it's a range of substantial
reasonable and limited Assurance
opinions and thankfully there were no
um no no Assurance opinions provided for
the council
and and page 43 has a has a simple pie
chart showing those those audit opinions
um the the text on there on the left
um talks about the the free limited
Assurance opinions we provided in year
and um we'll be doing
um work in the future to confirm that
those
um that management has has taken action
to to resolve those areas
of of weakness
uh page 44 so that talks about
um fraud detention sorry fraud
prevention and detection work
and members may recall Ken Johnson
coming to the uh induction session to
talk about um the importance of fraud
prevention and so on
um and obviously we're we're available
to support the Council on that
um from page 45 so
um so again members main over at uh
every audit committee we prevent the
summary of the of the audits that we've
done
um so from page 45 that's those are the
reports that we did since the March
audit committee
um and I indeed sent you copies of these
reports um of those reports
um about a week or so ago
you'll note that there are three
substantial reports on
on governance creditors and payroll
um and the other uh reports issued where
um were really reasonable
uh on on insurance business continuity
and information governance
um and then I just just highlight page
53 details some of the sort of very good
customer satisfaction scores that we get
so in in essence for every audit we send
out a customer satisfaction form and we
ask management to complete it in terms
of how well we did and so on so that's a
summary of our um of responses we've
received received today
um so yes so happy to take any any
questions from from members
thank you Paul for your very full report
there
do we have any
questions or observations members
Leanne
um can you say any more about the the
actions that are being taken on the
three limited limited audits or is
what's given here
um all that's kind of agreed on for the
moment
is that specifically the Estate
Management assets the housing options
and acts of storage it says that
um we've made recommendations to address
them which ones if you wanted to flesh
that out anymore yeah so the first one
so State Management
we've done a couple of pieces of work in
the last couple of years
um
members may be aware that a really good
asset management strategy was recently
well issued
um about six months ago it's really
detailed you know what assets does
council got and why and where they
located what we want to do with them and
so on and I know that their new sort of
State manager has got some plans to
introduce more effective management and
maintenance Arrangements in place to
ensure that the shift a bit of a shift
away from sort of reactive maintenance
to proactive maintenance to sure that
you know to reduce the cost and so on so
we'll we'll again be um looking at his
his work to improve Arrangements
um housing options so again
um I mean this audit committee had a
quite a large session
um two or three meetings ago on housing
options and talked about the proposals
to to purchase properties and and divide
them up and make them available for for
housing for homeless people
um obviously it's a significant area of
of Financial Risk for the for the
council so
um I'm sure they're quite focused on how
how to reduce that Financial liability
in the in the future and then active
torrage
um so yes so again you'll be aware of
that um the council took on took back in
the house for leisure service and
facilities and so on and created up um a
company we we went in and did a very
thorough audit and indeed will be coming
back into active leisure
um to to look at
um a how they've managed to address them
as weaknesses but B to do other work in
terms of ensuring that controls
are effective but I I don't suppose we
were surprised that we found quite a lot
because you know it's um well the
council had to take it back in the house
very quickly from a from a supplier
who's not doing good job so it was a
very much a rush job
um
um any questions on that or other areas
okay
thank you very much Paul thank you for
the explanation
um so we're happy to note
that agenda item and we will move on to
the
audit Plan update that's item 11 to
receive a verbal update from Grant
Thornton external Auditors over to you
Julie thank you
let's go thank you very much indeed
um just really two two items to to
update the committee on first of all
just firstly in terms of introductions
and uh welcome to to the new members um
my name is Julie mashi I'm the
engagement lead for for Grant Thornton
for the external Auditors
um we typically come to every meeting to
update you on the progress of the audit
and I understand that there was clearly
some uh some in-depth discussion at an
extraordinary meeting on the 27th of
June relating to the progress of the
2122 accounts
um I think all I would say at this stage
of this committee is I've I've formally
written to the council in response to
the discussions that were held at that
meeting and the council's decision
arising from that meeting because whilst
I clearly recognize some of the
frustrations that the council has the
decision that ultimately the council has
now come to as effectively
approved the fact that you will not just
your accounts for what is a material
correction to a key estimate I need to
obviously consider the implications of
that in terms of the progress of the
2122 audit I think it's important that I
sit down and have a much more in-depth
conversation with officers at the
authority before we decide what are the
net the best next steps to make sure
that we progress and close the remainder
of this audit as efficiently as possible
so I think it's important I put that
publicly on record but I don't think
it's appropriate that I have any more of
a discussion than that at this stage
until we've had the opportunity to talk
through that in more detail with with
officers so that's that's the position
in relation to the 21 22 audit
in terms of the 2223 audit and that work
has already started so the team have
been on site since the beginning of July
and very positive progress has been made
so far the finance officers have worked
very well with my audit team pretty much
all of the audit evidence has been
uploaded to our we have an online portal
called inflow which is what the officers
are used to upload all of the necessary
audit documentation to help progress the
audit work and that has has progressed
very well in the first first few weeks
of the work so far
a number of
have been issued
to address that
just
situation and later
the counts because you gave this
committee
that you would let
any delay
I was going to be
comment on that please
the meeting of
Michael
committee and clearly
um
inspiration that had
was all
day
and my colleague Andy sat here in the
committee the day after and gave you as
up-to-date a position on that as soon as
we became aware of it
if it's also important to say that
obviously we concluded the audit for the
audit on the 12th of March so we're
already progressing very well with the
final stages of conclusion of the 2122
audit it was just unfortunate that in
that two-week window obviously these
further National Developments had arose
and and what is required of Auditors
under the under the auditing standards
we have to take out of post-balance
sheet events that happen between the
balance sheet date and obviously the
point that I signed the opinion so we've
had to take that for that position
nationally as a firm across all Audits
and now we've had that National Clarity
and we've had further work undertaken to
assess the impact of the triennial
valuations across all local government
Audits and we've now presented what we
feel is the right way forward to all
authorities including torrage and we
just would like to progress that now to
a satisfactory resolution and bring the
audit to a close
okay thank you I note your comments but
perhaps it highlights The Perils of
delay in signing off and that was
something that this committee was very
alive to and obviously there is an
exchange of letters
which
um
the chief executor hasn't been
positioned as a report back on
he
would be a
to this stage
Bible
you've got actually
offer your best
to be accurate
that's what I'm going to say
thank you for contribution
right so
if there are no further
questions or observations I will simply
note
the item and we'll move forward to item
number 12 which is the forward plan on
page 56.
are you able to share a copy with me
I
right thank you
thank you
right
at the moment my screen is blank
for the
Ford
I don't think we have items in for the
future meetings at this stage
so we would I think it's broken down
into governance and
yeah
internal and external audits so if we
get key dates we can we can fill that
for the future meetings and I'll publish
it with the minutes okay yeah thanks
Karen not a problem there
right
um
we have no
part two items so I don't have to move
that we go into part two
so with that at two minutes to three
I'll declare the meeting